The joe rogan experience and I can't think you enough Joe for uh,
really sticking your neck out there.
And really,
I know you faced a lot of criticism for your supportive psychedelics.
Yeah,
no,
it's been pretty easy.
I'm going to be honest with you,
I'm sitting here given this like heartfelt
but it,
but I did take you seriously that day in the podcast when you told me mushrooms
could change the world and it really planted a seed in my head which sprouted
this journey that I've been doing around the world investigating these
medicines.
And that never would have happened.
My,
you know,
my life wouldn't be in such the amazing state.
I feel like it is in now.
If it hadn't been for you having the gumption to,
to talk about this and start this dialogue is our country.
Cause psychedelics have been so taboo,
especially in the mainstream and I,
and I think you're really helping to shift that consciousness nationwide.
I honestly don't think I am.
I think I'm just the whole thing itself.
It's very nice.
Tried to give me,
I don't deserve any credit,
nor do I want any.
I just,
um,
I,
I'm shocked that more people don't know about the experiences and I feel a duty
because I've been there.
It's just like if you and your friends were starving to death and you found some
food and the test and you're like,
guys,
come here.
Come here.
I found the food.
Would you want all this credit for finding that food?
No.
You'd want your friends to have the food.
That's how I feel.
I feel like,
uh,
you know what,
what we're all experiencing right now is a wait,
what moment?
The whole coach culture is going,
wait,
wait.
What?
Wait,
wait,
wait a minute.
The NSA's listening to my fucking emails.
They're listening to my voicemails.
They're reading my emails.
I don't do anything wrong,
man.
Come on.
I'm,
I'm a fucking insurance salesman.
And then,
and then people go,
wait,
wait.
What marijuana makes how much in fucking taxes for Colorado?
They make how much for we know we're running out of fucking money for schools
and we could pay for that with weed,
but p and people are going to smoke the same amount of weed anyway.
Statistically proven.
What the fuck is going on when they look at [inaudible] we're going to go into
Syria.
Wait,
well,
well what the fuck are we doing this?
Wait,
what moment is we're all a part of this?
what moment you're a big part of this.
Wait,
what moment you're a big part of it by they sticking your neck out about Bahrain
and about CNN and about,
you know,
working for a corporation and being honest about it,
you,
you stuck your neck out about it.
We're all just,
we're all forced into this reality.
We didn't ask to be here.
We were,
you know,
hey,
could you give birth to me so I can grow up in the 21st century and fake?
No,
this is what you get.
Nobody asked you.
This is what you get.
And I think all of us realize that that was the same for our far parents.
It was the same for our grandparents.
It was the same for everybody and nobody hit the brakes.
Nobody had the wait what moment where they went,
wait,
what the fuck are we doing?
Everybody just kept going and then had heart attacks and died and taught a bunch
of nonsense to their kids and they went and they had heart attacks and died
teaching a bunch of nonsense to their kids and then the internet came along and
that's the way,
what moment and the way,
what moment?
The real tipping point is people like you,
people like me,
people like anybody that's a part of the,
wait,
what moment doesn't like my new tee shirt?